.
THAT'S MY OPEN.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION TO
MY OPEN AND SO MUCH MORE, THE
HOST OF "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," THE ONE AND ONLY YOU
TUCKER CARLSON.
>> I'M SITTING HERE STUNNED BY
THE YOU CRAVEN STUCK-UPPERY OF
STEPHEN COLBERT.
YOU ARE NOT WRONG.
THIS IS THE MOST CYNICAL
ANTI-DEMCRATTER EXERCISE IN
AMERICAN POLITICS.
BIDEN GOT INTO THE RACE WHEN IT
WAS CLEAR THAT HE WASN'T UP FOR
IT.
SO HE RAN FOR PRESIDENT FOR THE
THIRD TIME AND GOT NO POPULAR
SUPPORT.
HE WAS AN AFTERTHOUGHT.
BERNIE SANDERS ROSE TO THE TOP
OF THE PACK AND THE DEMOCRATIC
ESTABLISHMENT DECIDE TO KNOCK
THIS GUY OUT.
SO THEY DID JUST THAT.
SO THEY DECIDED BIDEN WAS THE
PERFECT VESSEL FOR THEIR
AMBITION.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN DEMOCRACY, YOU
THINK WILL PEOPLE ELECT A
PRESIDENT BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
IN HIS CHARACTER AND VIEWS.
IT'S ABOUT THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE.
THEIR UNDERSTANDING WAS IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHO THE PERSON IS
AS LONG AS HE'S A SPOKESMAN FOR
THE OLIGARCHY THAT RUNS THE
COUNTRY.
UNFORTUNATELY TRUMP WAS SO
DISLIKED BY DEMOCRATIC VOTERS
AND THOUGH THEY UNDERSTOOD WAS
WAS GOING ON, AT LEAST HE WASN'T
TRUMP.
SO THIS PRESIDENT GOT ELECTED BY
THE AND HERE WE ARE.
IT'S HARD TO ATTACK JOE BIDEN.
I HAVE KNOWN JOE BIDEN FOR
DECADES.
JOE BIDEN IS A VERY FRIENDLY
GUY.
HE'S WRONG ON EVERYTHING.
BUFF HE'S A FRIENDLY PERSON.
BUFF NOW HE'S DIMINISHED IT'S
HARD TO ATTACK HIM.
HE HAS DEMENTIA.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOU FEEL BAD FOR
HIM BUT HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
HE'S TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAYING I CAN DO
THIS.
IT APPEARS THE FBI AND THE DOJ
ARE OPERATING SEPARATE FROM HIM.
WE SHOULDN'T FEEL BAD FOR HIM,
WE SHOULD FEEL BAD FOR
OURSELVES.
TUCKER: I'M FILLED WITH
SELF-PITY ABOUT IT EVERY DAY,
BELIEVE ME.
YOU COULDN'T REALLY PICK A
BETTER ONE TO TAKE OVER THE
OLIGARCHY.
YOU COULD LOOK AT RON KLAIN AND
I YOU ARE AN ILLEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT TRYING TO DESTROY THE
COUNTRY YOU INHERITED.
HE LITERALLY HAS DEMENTIA.
IT'S BRILLIANT AS SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN FOISTED ON THE
PUBLIC.
IF YOU WANTED TO PICK A CUTOUT,
YOU WOULD PICK BIDEN.
JUDGE JEANINE: PEOPLE ARE ALMOST
LOCKED IN IN TERMS OF DOING
ANYTHING BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE
OPTION IS KAMALA HARRIS.
EVEN THE AD SHE DID, YOU CAN SEE
WITH YOUR EYES AND FACE.
COME ON.
TUCKER: THAT'S RIGHT.
SHE IS THE LIVING EMBODIMENT OF
WHAT BIDEN IS WHICH IS A MIDDLE
FINGER TO THE IDEA OF DEMOCRACY.
SHE GOT ELECTED TO THE SENATE IN
A STATE THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY.
KAMALA HARRIS WAS DEEPLY
UNPOPULAR AMONG DEMOCRATS IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THEY ARE REFLEXIVE VOTERS SO
SHE GOT ELECTED.
SHE IS STILL THE MOST FULLY
CONSCIOUS PERSON IN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
IS THAT DEMOCRACY?
IT'S KIND OF REAL, IT'S NOT
TOTALLY RESPONSIVE TO THE
PUBLIC, BUT BASICALLY THE PUBLIC
GETS TO CHOOSE ITS OWN LEADERS.
THE LAST FIVE YEARS HAS PROVED
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
IF YOU ELECT SOMEBODY THEY DON'T
LIKE, THEY DESTROY HIM.
JUDGE JEANINE: MIKE FLYNN IS THE
GUY OBAMA HATED AND IT CONTINUED
EVEN DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WITH A JUDGE ON
THE BENCH SAYING I'M GOING TO
THROW MY ROBE OFF AND GET DOWN
AS A PROSECUTOR AND PROSECUTE
HIM FOR TREASON.
HE WASN'T CHARGED WITH TREASON.
CAN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THIS MAN.
TUCKER: I FLATTER MYSELF, I
THINK I'M SOPHISTICATED.
IT TOOK ME YEARS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT HAPPENED WITH MIKE FLYNN.
IT TOOK ME MANY MONTHS TO DIG
-- TOFIGURE OUT THAT JOE BIDENS
GOING TO GET ELECTED.
TRUMP GETS ELECTED, BY'S NOT
REALLY IN CHARGE OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT,
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES WHO STILL
EFFECTIVELY REPORT TO BARACK
OBAMA.
YOU CAN CHANGE THE NAME OF THE
GUY RUNNING THINGS BUT YOU DON'T
CHANGE THE PEOPLE RUNNING
THINGS.
THAT'S A PERMANENT RULING CLASS
THAT RUNS EVERYTHING WITHOUT
REGARD TO WHAT VOTERS WANT.
THAT'S SCARY AND IT'S HARD TO
INTERNALIZE THAT IF YOU BELIEVE
IN THE BASIC AMERICAN IDEALS,
BUT IT'S TRUE.
JUDGE JEANINE: FOR SOMEONE LIKE
ME WITH 32 YEARS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I SAID IF THERE ARE NO
PROSECUTIONS TO ALL THESE PEOPLE
WHO LIED TO CONGRESS WHERE A
NORMAL GUY GOES TO JAIL.
I HAVE TO QUESTION, WHAT DID I
DO FOR 30 YEARS?
JUSTICE SHOULD BE THE SAME FOR
EVERYONE.
I'M BECOMING MORE AND MORE
DISILLUSIONED.
IS IT STILL AMERICA?
TUCKER: WHAT IS AMERICA?
AMERICA AS A SYSTEM ABOVE ALL
ELSE, EVEN OUR MARKET ECONOMY,
AMERICA IS EQUAL TREATMENT UNDER
THE LAW.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TREATS
EVERYBODY EQUAL UNDER THE LAW.
THAT THE CORE PROMISE.
IF YOU UNDO THAT.
WHAT ARE YOU LEFT WITH?
NOT MUCH.
IT'S NOT JUST ONE EXAMPLE, THE
PRESIDENT'S SON COMMITS A
FEDERAL GUN CRIME AND ISN'T
CHARGED.
YOU GET TO SHOOT ASHLI BABBITT
AND NO ONE IS HELD TO ACCOUNT
FOR IT.
OPPONENTS OF THE REGIME ARE
PUNISHED, ALLIES OF THE REGIME
ARE NOT.
YOU CAN LITERALLY LOOT MACY'S
AND IF YOU TRY TO DEFEND YOUR
OWN PROPERTY WITH A GUN YOU ARE
INDICTED BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT
VOTING FOR BIDEN.
JUDGE JEANIN